domingo hermann taking his warm-ups
right into your living room
hermann is two and two with a 4.32
era went down to the alternate side and
he's been much better since returning
three starts 2-0 with a 2.50
trey turner leading on 3-2 to turner's
grounded up the middle
to his right lemay who backhands off
balance throw on one hop
and not in time and ford the first
baseman could not hang on to it
on the short hop turner beats the play
so an infield hit for turner and now
josh harrison stands in
fly ball right field
frazier makes the catch one down
now here is juan soto grounded to second
there's one and there's two it's a four
six three double play and the yankees
played soto very well
joe ross first time career against the
yankees making start number six of the
year for the nationals
again two and two record four point
three nine era dj in the batters box
breaking ball pull to the ground to
short easy play for turner couple of
crow hops in the throw to bell
in time to get lemayo and there's one
away so now giancarlo stanton who is
hitless to the series
so a one-out walk to stand in front of
aaron hicks who's moved up to the number
three spot of the order
swung on hit of the ear to center field
playable though
for victor robles back a couple of steps
he makes the catch for the out
nick's flies out standing back to first
and two away here in the bottom of the
first inning here's claber torres
swinging a [ __ ] struck him out
first strikeout for ross a one out walk
in a man left one away here in the top
of the second
inning and now the old one swung on
that's hit hard to center and deep
hicks going back won't get there and
this one is off the base of the wall in
left center
and castro coasts into second base with
his seventh double of the year
so he's in scoring position with one out
now with an eight-game hitting streak
kyle schwarber standing in for the left
side caught on and missed breaking ball
down and in terrific pitch i think ramon
is much better than people
think so there are two out and here is
john gomes
he's popped up to shallow right forward
backpedaling ford makes the catch
in shallow right field to end the inning
and that'll do it for the nationals who
strand the cash drawn as one out double
joe ross issues a one out four pitch
walk
so now we'll face clint frazier he's
hitting just 150
12 out of 80. swing he's jammed hits a
fly ball to right
coming in is yadiel hernandez and on the
move makes a one-handed grab with a
glove in the left hand
frasier's out two away here in the
bottom of the second and after the walk
in the first hitting ross got a fly ball
to the outfield for the second out
so now miguel and duhar swung on
fastball hit on the ground through the
middle
and fielded by harrison he'll throw onto
bell on the side retired
a walk and a man left for the yankees
who've left a man each inning hermann
looking for his first one two three
inning vermont facing trey turner
swinging a little looper into shallow
right center this one may fall and it
will it dunks in front of frazier
and trey turner has his first multi-in
game of the series
an infield hit on a blooper and the
nationals have a two out base runner
that'll bring up harrison
my ball right field fairly deep going
back frazier on the track he makes the
play and that'll do it
this is what the yankees do they they
don't steal bases they don't
particularly get a lot of hits but they
draw walks and now ross
who's had four base runners against him
all on walks
now let's see if the yankees can get the
hit and that's going to bring up
aaron hicks line drive it's a base hit
to right center field goldman rounds
third
he's coming home it's an rbi single for
hicks
yankees on the board they lead one
nothing and ross pays for the walks
here's gleber torres broken back ground
ball a deep at short sliding stop turner
to second for one harrison to first
not in time the yankees will have
runners at first and third with two down
as gary sanchez makes his way to the
plate is a slider swung on and missed
and the inning over so the yankees turn
a couple of walks into a run with one
hit
so domingo harman comes out with a
one-nothing lead at the end of three
bell cuts and misses had a change by
hermann
and that is mingo's third strikeout
castro
gets a four pitch walk see if the
nationals can make him pay for the walk
here's kyle schwarber he struck out his
first time up schwarber
oh nice play by ford taking himself and
that'll end the inning
joe russ you talk about a mixed bag of a
day only one hit
but four walks and leading off for the
yankees will be the first baseman
mike ford the o2 and he struck him out
swinging with a high fastball
so that three pitch sequence is the best
of the day for joe ross so hopefully
maybe he can settle into a rhythm here
swinging a miss got him with a high
fastball so back-to-back strikeouts
in the bottom of the fourth and ross has
now
fanned five possible send up the bottom
third of the order
against tremont swing and a miss gomes
down on strikes one away fifth strikeout
for hermann
fitz is cut out and missed on another
breaking ball
and he has a one two three so glebe
torres will lead off
against joe ross it's just one nothing
so now to remind everybody paulus
predicted either a home run for glabor
or for anduhar in this game out on a
limb michael you never know he just got
that feeling right
that one's driving deep to left field
there it goes
see ya o'neal on the money
he made the call and torres delivered
two-nothing yanks
that's a big monkey off the back of
glaber torres too and there was a no
doubter
so really the decision back fires on
davey martinez i thought ross might be
done
surviving the fifth but davey lets him
continue
he throws one strike and that ball was
hit into orbit garmon's still out there
as we start the seventh inning so here's
schwarber runner and sagging one out
look at schwarber and he just scares me
one mistake
i mean he has tremendous power schwarber
gets one high in the year to right fair
see you later it wasn't a bad toss
it was more like a microphone drop and
he ties the game just like that well
that is going to do it for herman
so first and second one man out that
brings up stanton oh it's become a very
high leverage spot now
swinging a line drive up the middle on
one off harrison has it to turner for
one on to first for two
a double play soft line drive back up
the middle and austin voth
survives a big time yankee threat they
walk
forward intentionally so they're
choosing to pitch to clint frazier
instead of mike ford so they certainly
laid down the gauntlet for frasier
pops it up playable on the infield for
josh harrison
on the infield dirt onto the outfield
grass one hands it
and the side retired hand is a top right
reliever but career against the yankees
he has a bloated 5.87 era
he's allowed multiple runs in each of
his last three appearances against the
yanks so
now the winning run is at third base
here's stan the guy who's been
their hottest hitter for a long time now
he has yet to pick up a hit in this
series though
and the yankees win three to two stanton
with an rbi
single the yankees walk it off two days
in a row
and they complete an outstanding home
stand